well we start in the United States where
coronavirus infection and fatality rates
are rising fast and now the countries
for most infectious diseases expert has
given his prediction of just how bad
things will get dr. Anthony Fauci says
there could be between a hundred and two
hundred thousand deaths in the US and
millions of cases his warning comes as
the federal government considers rolling
back some containment measures meanwhile
in Europe Spain recorded another eight
hundred and thirty-eight deaths on
Saturday that's a new high
it's infection rate however was lower
and in the UK there's been 209 deaths in
the past 24 hours raising the total
there to 2118 a short time ago the
housing minister says the UK hasn't
experienced such emergency measures
since World War two well we have several
correspondents covering all these latest
developments Francesca manat she is
standing by in Rome as we're waiting for
new figures out of Italy Sonia Garro
will bring us all the updates from the
UK she's in London but first let's go to
Alan Fisher in Washington DC Alan some
really grim numbers there a grim
prediction from Anthony Falchi well we
knew that there would be somewhere in
the region of a million or more cases
that's something the experts have been
saying for a while for dr. 30 to talk in
terms of 100 to 200,000 deaths that's
really quite a stark reality on a Sunday
morning he says it's a moving target and
you can see that from the figures he's
given these are not precise figures he's
working from models that they had being
presented with on one hand there's
100,000 on the other there's 200,000 and
we were talking about people's lives
that is a very big gap indeed he said
that every town every city every state
has to make preparations for the
worst-case scenario because he says you
simply can't gamble on it being the
best-case scenario whenever the model
has come in they give a worst-case
scenario and a best-case scenario
generally the reality is somewhere in
the middle I've never seen a model of
the diseases that I've dealt with which
the worst-case scenario actually came
out they always overshoot so when you
use number
like a million a million and a half two
million that almost certainly is off the
chart now it's not impossible but very
very unlikely so it's difficult to
present I mean looking at what we're
seeing now you know I would say between
100 and 200 thousand cases but I don't
want to be held to that because it's
it's it's excuse me deaths I mean we're
gonna have millions of cases but I just
don't think that we really need to make
a projection when it's such a moving
target that you could so easily be wrong
and mislead people what we do know Jake
is that we got a serious problem in New
York we have a serious problem in New
Orleans and we're going to be developing
serious problems in other areas and
Allen as we've been saying there's been
some fairly public criticism including
from government officials of just how
the White House has been handling this
especially now conflicting statements on
a potential quarantine where do we stand
now on all that well when you hear
Andrew Cuomo talking about the numbers
in New York 56 percent of the cases in
the United States are based in New York
State itself and Andrew Cuomo says the
reality is the apex of the virus there
would hit for another two to three weeks
now in two weeks time will bang right up
against Easter and that's the time when
Donald Trump had said just last week
just a few days ago that if he was
hoping that the country would start to
reopen and the churches would be full
certainly what we're hearing from the
experts is that that is unlikely Anthony
Fauci highlighted a case there when he
says look we're growing numbers in New
Orleans that's because there was Mardi
Gras there in the run-up to easter one
and a half million people in New Orleans
it's normally a big celebration but of
course they went ahead with that the
Louisiana governor and the mayor of New
Orleans because at that point the
federal government Donald Trump and
others were saying we have this under
control there's 15 cases and soon it
will be down to zero so they felt there
was no reason for them to cancel this
huge economic driver for the south the
reality is many more people would
probably be infected because of that
and if they live in this South then
there's a real problem there because the
health services in the south of the
United States aren't as well developed
as places as Los Angeles New York
Seattle and therefore that's a problem
and also there are more underlying
conditions now until iPhoto and others
are saying we can perhaps think about
maybe possibly opening up the country in
bits but we have to understand there has
to be extensive testing in those areas
and at the moment the US isn't quite
geared up for that so the idea that in
two weeks time the u.s. is going to be
seeing open for business again just goes
against what all the experts are telling
us and certainly goes against what
Andrew Cuomo the governor of New York
and others are saying in that it's two
to three weeks before this virus Peaks
in New York and then there could be
other peaks in other parts of the
country this is going to go on for some
time and the White House is beginning to
realize that indeed Allen Fisher there
we've actually also just been hearing
from New York Governor Andrew Cuomo we
were showing you some of those like live
pictures we'll be bringing you all the
latest on that as we get those lines in
thanks again Alan well let's cross now
to us on yaga yaga she is joining us
live via Skype from London
Sonia we've literally just heard in the
last hour from the British government
with their daily update talk us through
what they had to say today well
fundamentally Nastasia it's really to
give an outline of exactly how serious
the government's coordination and
response is relation to this crisis here
now it is a strategist a blushing
strategic coordination centers led by
gold commanders and as you mentioned
earlier housing minister said there
hadn't been this level of response
coordination since seen in the country
since World War two just to give you an
idea of how much effort is going into
this to try and not have too much strain
on the National Health Service even
though it is already seeing that some of
the strain already now they will be
coordinating with the military as well
and with some of the first response
units ambulances as well there is also
planning
to get personal protection equipment to
health workers especially those in the
front line as quickly as possible now
this has been a very um Stern cause for
concern for many in the health service
you've been crying out that they don't
have enough that personal protection
equipment with which to be able to do
their jobs as well now it's not just
those working across the National Health
Service the 58,000 National Health
Service health care facilities that
there are in the country but you're
talking about pharmacies as well
dentists care homes for the elderly as
well as also for social care workers
those personal protection equipment is
going to be rolled out to them over the
coming week now when you look at how the
NHS has been dealing with this as well
there is also concerned that about
testing as well and equipments not
getting quickly enough to them the
government did pledge on Saturday that
it was cutting the red tape to be able
to have access to things such as hand
sanitizers it's also said that there is
a lack of globe worldwide of certain
objects like this but also it needs to
have things like for example components
for test testing for health workers in
the UK as well is of an enormous concern
as well and the urgency to get those as
quickly as possible done and God is of
parent is paramount importance really
because of course those who are feeling
any of the symptoms have to stay away
for two weeks thereby putting more
strain on the health system now we
relate in relation to the deaths of
course there still seems to be an idea
that there they are pretty much on line
with the debt war costs that's seen in
Italy as well the UK may not be seeing
the same number of deaths as they are in
Italy in Spain in France but it seems to
be on track to be preparing itself to
see some of those numbers here as well
and that again is of course the concern
and that's why the underlying message
every time there is a spokesperson out
there as a science officer medical
officer the message is the same stay
indoors practice social distancing
that's the only way that they can get
there the curve pushed as far away as
possible to avoid any strain on the
handset
India Tonya Hagar there live for us in
London Thank You Sonia